greetings boys and girls my flavor one
of his family little girl cats
this is alley cat she gets so excited
Jesus Newhouse did that you don't see
alley cat when she's my little baby girl
this is one of the original samurais
daughters she don't [ __ ] around so she's
sitting with me my son introduce it to
you that's my little girl Ali stay
black.they Somali taking this [ __ ] of
life I came too early it's a price cut
we're gonna do things a battle over I
can't be into world that with a purpose
my wife had some oatmeal god yeah I
couldn't even goof up be planning some
great to the bathroom
they couldn't smells like death in here
but what he heard them Weight Watchers
[ __ ] this is where it all goes down
I'm mixing the Dolce stuff with weight
watch it's like a jeet kune doll of a
fat [ __ ] dude this filthy animal
right here on Hollywood Boulevard
looking [ __ ] tremendous you know I'm
saying look at this Hollywood Boulevard
ladies and gentlemen a little while
mad flavor LAX Felicia Michaels were
headed to San Francisco the cops living
like a doctor stay black
[ __ ] bad flavor here going over
all the goodies I got his presence in
San Francisco last night let's take a
look I got these mom [ __ ] and lollipops
right here this is passionfruit look at
how beautiful that's candy [ __ ] porn
what flavor is this
lemon whoo I got these blunts of death
here right here look at these
[ __ ]
I got this [ __ ] somebody game it's
called the white look at this bad boy
here then somebody brought me a bag of
peanut butter and jelly but that they
grew themselves and this is the [ __ ]
this is what nobody's got the country
people oh yeah we got girls got
[ __ ] cookies up here in San
Francisco take a look at these
[ __ ] here and I'm about to
[ __ ] sparking my rules so what you do
when you want to spark in your room is
yeah well these things here you take
this
and nobody smells the smoke that's how
we're doing it out here in Cali
so keep telling yourself Joey we got
good weed to come knock you're not
getting this [ __ ] see I'm gonna prepare
my little kit I put it in there I put
this on top of here
this comes complete with my [ __ ] one
in and my line up and that's how we're
doing it that's what I do I'm a slavers
world I add you Kate you [ __ ]
don't jump rocks up this
joy comedy is sitting in the green room
in Sacramento
my little princess Felicia Michaels
there or issue there she is right there
is how we do it you know I'm on the wall
goes down
[Music]
is my man mad flavor with Felicia
Michaels Steven Bauer being the Beast
the hundredth anniversary [ __ ] stick
that your pipe smoking stay black Steven
bow I love you [ __ ]
[Music]